ja ich bekomme sie zum neuen jahr ich
wünsche ihnen alles gute für das jahr
2009/10 und wir beginnen mit einem
kleinen rückblick und zwar auf ein seit
chris haben sie das alle bekommen von
mir per e mail
also wir können das mal zusammen machen
wenn sie mal auf meine seite philo cast
net gehen dann finden sie hier
eben unter anderem videos der
relativitätstheorie über die
relativitätstheorie über die mysterien
des weltalls können sich hier alles
schauen ich habe hier mal das ganze netz
durchsucht nach interessanten themen
fernsehsendungen das können sie hier
alles nachschauen insbesondere kann ich
diese sendung empfehlen mysterien des
weltalls zeit weil hier wirklich die
aktuellsten ergebnisse der
physikalischen forschung hier auch
behandelt werden ja das stimmt aber wenn
sie es über die app öffnen dann können
sie es sehen also das ist rechtlich
geschützt das hat youtube wieder
rausgenommen
aber wenn sie das über die app oder auch
über viera cast punkt net öffnen dann
können sie es seltsamerweise direkt
sehen alle anderen sendungen auch mit
harald lesch diesem netten herren hier
können sie also regulär auch über
youtube sehen dann machen wir doch mal
hier kurz dieses kleine quiz was
versteht man unter liberal derzeit sie
durch und einfach hier mir sagen sie
können eine oder mehrere antworten hier
wählen die erste möglichkeit einen
zeitstrahl der sich vom zeitlichen
anfang bis zum ende der welt erstreckt
ähnlich einen zahlen strahlen zweite
möglichkeit die zeit indem es ihn früher
als und später als eingeteilt werden
kann oder die dritte möglichkeit die
zukünftige gegenwärtigen vergangene zeit
was soll ich hier ankreuzen können sie
das gut erkennen kann man das
einigermaßen erkennen
ich gehe noch ein bisschen runter so was
soll ich ankreuzen haben sie vorschläge
die zweite gibt sonst noch eine
möglichkeit oder warst du schon ja ja
vielleicht sagen sie noch kurze
begründung warum das erste halte das
ähnlich das ähnlich ist natürlich immer
wagen es gibt dann auch noch die zwei
derzeit jetzt schauen wir mal ob das
hier stimmt checken wir das mal und es
wird alles richtig ausgespuckt dritten
die dritte option zukünftige
gegenwärtigen vergangene zeit das ist
eben die arbeit dass ich dies die zeit
so empfinde mit einer subjektiven stelle
gehen wir zur nächsten frage über welche
volk welche der folgenden behauptungen
ist war kann vertritt einen
transzendentalen realismus bezüglich der
zeit nach leibnitz existiert keine
absolute zeit nach newton existiert eine
absolute zeit augustinus vertritt eine
reine theorie derzeit schelling
entwickelt ein vertikales zeit modell
welches geschichte verständlich machen
so gibt es jetzt mehrere mögliche also
mehrere richtige antworten was soll ich
machen ja
23.45 auch wie sieht es mit dem ersten
aus ja was soll das mit augustinus nicht
jetzt haben wir also eine reine eine
gegenthese ein kommilitone möchte dass
wir auch an kreuzen gegen ein wind oder
also der kommilitone sagt b
bereinigt sei und wie sieht es mit also
mit der ersten möglichkeit aus vertritt
jetzt kann ein trans and arlen realismus
bezüglich der zeit
ok zwar ein bisschen gemein von mir da
habe ich versucht eine falle zu stellen
trans zentraler realismus bedeutet eben
dass die zeit als grundbedingung der
erkenntnis objektiv unabhängig von
unserer subjektivität existiert und das
sagt kann eben letztendlich nicht
also hat ein trans and arlen idealismus
der bezüglich derzeit vertritt und
augustinus ist eben eine der ganz stark
die a3 ins zentrum stellt und schelling
ist glaube ich klar
also es wird als richtig angezeigt ich
erinnere mich auch nicht mehr selbst
welche fragen ich alles richtig
klassifiziert hatte als insofern ist es
für mich auch nochmal eine neue
herausforderung
und jetzt haben wir glaube ich die
letzte frage in welche konsequenzen
ergeben sich aus albert einsteins
spezielle relativitätstheorie erste
option die zeit verläuft in sehr schnell
bewegten systemen langsamer als im
vergleichsweise langsameren systemen
je mehr wir uns der lichtgeschwindigkeit
annähern umso langsamer altern wir
dritte option raum und zeit sind
voneinander abhängig
können sie das lesen geht es sie könnte
es auch über die app können sie das auch
machen als wenn sie jetzt ihre app hier
öffnen
das smartphone hernehmen können sie das
direkt aus der app heraus starten da
hätten wir kurze begründung
eine raumzeit mehr werden immer in einem
raum zeigt man hat nicht nur eine zeit
einen raum diesem in kowski räume wo
eben wenn auch so eine vierte dimension
haben also da kommt dann kommen dann die
koordinaten beim in kowski diese
rechnung kommt dann also x1 x2 und x3
das ist der raum und dann kommt hier
immer noch so ein thema mit rein
manchmal auch das noch mit zehn
multipliziert das dann diese vierte
dimension die noch mit rein kommt wir
können also diese räumlichen koordinaten
nach dieser relativitätstheorie nicht
mehr von zeit drinnen die muss immer mit
reinkommen und in der allgemeinen
relativitätstheorie die wir gar nicht
behandelt hatten hier die ist viel zu
kompliziert da geht es dann soweit das
eben der raum auch noch gekrümmt wird
und somit in gravierender gravitations
systeme da sind dann wird muss der raum
gekrümmt gedacht werden und hat man also
nicht mehr irgendwelche geraden linien
sind hat man sogenannte geodäten das
sind also punkte erstrecken die die
kürzesten die kürzeste differenz zwar
die kürzeste strecke zwischen zwei
punkten markieren die aber wenn neben
der raum gekrümmt ist eben auch gekrümmt
sind und das wird dann noch kompliziert
aber dasselbe gilt hier auch aber der
kommilitone hat glaube ich recht
jedenfalls habe ich genauso gesehen das
heißt nicht dass das wahr ist aber also
das stimmt jedenfalls sind mein mit
meinen fragen und antwort zur über ein
jetzt schon mal die evolution also wir
haben alles richtig so ein guter start
ins neue jahr wenn sie dieses quiz noch
machen wollen schauen sie einfach hier
auf viele cast und sie werden dann auch
noch ein weiteres quiz finden was ein
bisschen umfangreicher ist können sie
übrigens auch über die app machen
nämlich ein freiheit determinismus quiz
was
auch angebunden ist an ein seminar aus
diesem semester von mir und sogar noch
ein kausalität quiz wenn sie sich ein
bisschen mit der frage befassen wollen
was ursachen und wirkungen sind dann
können sie das auch mal hier
ausprobieren jetzt nur als ein kleiner
exkurs das war das zeit quiz und jetzt
habe ich ihn schon gesagt wenn sie sich
also noch mal ein bisschen mit der
relativitätstheorie befassen wollen die
anschaulich erklärt wird kann ich ihnen
diese drei videos empfehlen die ich auf
die lowcost gestellt haben können sich
einfach anschauen wir sind sehr gut
verständlich
dann wurde ich gebeten etwas zu
hausarbeiten zu sagen dass möchte
hiermit tun ich habe ihn ja auch allen
glaube ich dieses merkblatt
herumgeschickt haben sie das alle
bekommen mein herdplatte also wenn sie
jetzt bei der präsentation meiner punkte
fragen haben können sie die jederzeit
stellen
also wir können die themen absprechen
also es themen gibt es ja nicht gibt dem
haus arbeitsthemen die können sie mir
sie können wir zb eine e mail schicken
in der sie mich fragen ist dieses thema
geeignet glauben sie dass dieses thema
geeignet ist ich muss eben dazu sagen
nicht jedes thema ist gleichermaßen gut
geeignet für hausarbeiten da wir sind ja
hier in einem bachelor seminar das heißt
der umfang ist auch nicht so groß von
ausarbeiten
sie haben nicht so viel raum deswegen
ist es ganz wichtig sich zu
konzentrieren auf eine bestimmte
leitfrage ich sage es noch ein bisschen
ausführlicher und am besten sich mit mir
kurze verbindung setzen also schreiben
sie eine e-mail ist dieses thema ist
diese leitfrage in ordnung ist diese
sache bewältigbar und ich werde auch
noch eine liste mit möglichen hausarbeit
themen auch auf die lowcost stellen
das wäre wichtig lassen sie noch ein
bisschen zeit legen sie sich nicht zu
früh fest weil sie merken im verlauf
dieses seminars werden wir noch
die ein oder anderen interessanten
erkenntnisse gewinnen die sie auch noch
mit einbeziehen können
25.000 zeichen sind circa zehn bis zwölf
seiten schauen sie dass sie nicht zu
sehr darunter liegen sie können
natürlich drüber liegen gerne aber
möglichst nicht drunter liegen dann ist
der letztmögliche abgabetermin
fünfundzwanzigster märz 2009 10 um 23
uhr 59 bis es schreibe ich jetzt dass
eine seltsame zeit hin gleich gleich ein
weil sie mir die arbeit nicht händisch
ausgeben nicht physikalisch sondern mir
als e-mail-anhang schicken herr pdf und
möglichst eben bis zum 25 metern achten
und danach geht es vielen
danach geht's auch nicht mehr also nein
sie halten bitte diese zeit ein
und dann kriegen sie auch noch eine
bestätigung bitte
ich glaube inklusive ja die sind da
eingerechnet werden ja ja also zehn bis
zwölf seiten als inklusive leerzeichen
die sind da schon drin ja und zwar eine
eine m als eine maß der seminararbeit
und fast 40.000 zeichen inklusive
leerzeichen
die ist also deutlich umfangreicher sie
sind die aber hier in einem bachelor
seminar ok schicken sie mit ist einfach
möglichst bis zum 25
13 23 uhr 59 per e mail mit einer
betriebs seine hausarbeit zeit seminar
dann kann ich das besser am ende finden
falls sie krank sein sollten was ich
ihnen nicht wünsche was wir jetzt alle
nicht hoffen wollen falls sie es aber so
schwer sein sollten dass sie die
hausarbeit nicht schreiben können oder
nicht pünktlich abgeben können müssten
sie rechtzeitig mit dem prüfungsamt
kontakt aufnehmen das hat ihn aber
bestimmt schon jemand anderes gesagt
also dass sie einfach wissen dann müssen
sie dann attest vorlegen
in ausnahmefällen wenn sie jetzt einmal
eine erkältung haben oder so oder
dann schreiben sie mich noch mal an ich
kann aber längere verlängerungsfrist
nicht gäbe also ein bisschen kann man
dann noch mit mir verhandeln
also wenn sie jetzt nicht schwer krank
sind und irgendwie irgendwas noch
dazwischen kam war es jetzt nicht attest
mäßig belegt werden kann wenn sie das
gut begründen in einer e-mail mehr
schreiben rechtzeitig dann kann man dann
noch ein bisschen drüber reden aber im
normalen fall entweder sie sind dann
eben so krank dass sie was ich nicht
hoffe dass sie ein attest bekommen oder
eben nicht aber wenn es irgendwas
dazwischen käme was sie nicht
verantworten können und was sie davon
abhalten sollte die arbeit noch
rechtzeitig abzugeben
dann schreiben sie einfach eine e-mail
kann man darüber noch mal reden dann zur
schriftart also immer diese times new
roman ist mir wichtig schriftgröße 12
und für die fußnoten schriftgröße 10
den textblock satz bitte formatieren und
mit 15
zeilenabstand formatieren und die
fußnoten genügt ein einfacher sein
abstimmen und die zeit seitenzahlen
bitte auch nicht vergessen
ich sage jetzt im folgenden noch ein
paar dinge die meine erfahrungen mit
hausarbeiten treffen ich habe ja schon
ziemlich viele gelesen im letzten
semester habe ich 80 hausarbeiten
korrigieren müssen und da hab ich jetzt
doch die ein und andere punkte
kennengelernt die sich immer wiederholen
also vergessen sie nicht die
seitenzahlen das ist auch wichtig und
untersuchen sie den text vor der abgabe
gründlich auf rechtschreibfehler
insbesondere kommasetzung ich weiß nicht
womit das zusammenhängt ich glaube da
ist nach der seit der neuen
rechtschreibreform eine große irritation
eingetreten unter den studierenden was
die kommasetzung anbetrifft aber ich
meine doch dass selbst nach dieser neuen
rechtsform der so neu gar nicht mehr ist
immer komm ass vor solchen unterordnen
konjunktionen hingehören also wie zb
weil das obwohl da in dem das ist
wichtig da sie der vorpommer setzen weil
damit eben auch noch mal eine gliederung
erreicht wird commerce gliedern einen
satz komm ass gliedern ein gedanken
commerce trennen übergeordnetes von
untergeordneten ihn setzen also
abhängigkeitsverhältnisse von gedanken
kommt da jetzt eine begründung kommt da
jetzt ein geständnis kommt da jetzt eine
konsequenz so was sollten sie eben mit
diesen konjunktionen und auch mit einem
komma davor eben deutlich machen
und relativ setzte auch natürlich als
alles solche abhängigkeitsverhältnisse
sollten sie in sätzen mit commerce
markieren
dann machen sie ein titelblatt am anfang
und ich mache das jetzt mal auf also sie
haben hier das ist jetzt mal das
titelblatt und in der mitte haben sie
hier also obertitel oder artikel so groß
muss es vielleicht nicht sein untertitel
titel bisher größer formaten als im
untertitel
dann können sie also hier machen sie
dann zb informationen zum seminar also
welches lied wie das seminar ist theorie
der zeit wann es war winter
wintersemester 18 19 mein name dozent
prozent zeit universität und hier unten
links das können sie auch spiegeln wie
sie wollen hier machen sie informationen
zu ihrer person verfasser informationen
und da schreiben es dann also hin ihre
hausnummer oder ihre straße interessiert
mich auch gar nicht interessiert mich
gar nicht wo sie wohnen sie das brauchen
sie dann nicht in schreiben aber steil
sie ihre ihre e mail schreiben sie hin
und ihren matrikelnummer schreiben sie
da hin weil es kann sein dass ich dann
dass hier mehr dass ich zwei teilnehmer
habe die denselben namen haben
ingo müller oder oder hans meyer
das gibt es ja sehr häufig und dann
komme ich vielleicht durcheinander und
dann erlaubt es mit die matrikelnummer
die zwei personen zu unterscheiden
also informationen hier das ist das
wichtig ist jetzt hier der titel als ich
sag mal so es ist schon eine kunst einen
guten titel zu finden also importierte
obertitel hat hat seinen hut sein wert
und da überlegen sich was sie können sie
gerne auch ein bisschen portieren
also könnte eine frage stellen der
obertitel kann in form einer frage
auftreten
da können sie durchaus kreativ sein und
der untertitel sollte dann ein bisschen
präziser sein also der sollte dann in
die zum verhältnis von zeit und raum bei
berg sondern das ist ein bisschen
konkreter aber der obertitel muss jetzt
zum beispiel nicht auch den namen des
philosophen enthalten um den die arbeit
geht können zum beispiel sagen also mal
beispiel sie könnten schreiben obertitel
schichten derzeit oder zeitschichten
schichten derzeit finde ich jetzt
eigentlich mal gut und ein untertitel
schellings theorie der geschichte in den
weltalter von 1811
dass ich so ein bisschen sagt können sie
an die metapher reinnehmen hier
obertitel im eigentlichen titel ist
importieren bisschen spielen mit der
sprache und der untertitel wird dann
ganz genau der untertitel heißt darum
geht es dann eigentlich und vielleicht
erklärt auch der untertitel die etwas
pointierte verwendung des artikels tanne
da können sie ein bisschen ästhetisch
arbeiten auch ein zitat können sie
nehmen wenn sie ein kurzes zitat haben
können sie das auch als obertitel nehmen
wenn sie da ein gutes zitat finden zum
beispiel die zeit ist irgendwas ich weiß
die zeit ist ein subjekt sagt der
schellings meint diese art und dann
können sie also sage schädigen würde
sagen was jetzt nicht direkt wörtlich so
sagt aber in der szene nach die zeit ist
ein subjekt also es wäre jetzt das tat
die zeit ist ein subjekt und untertitel
können sein schreiben schellings organo
logische oder schellings theologischer
theorie der geschichte dass sowas nenne
wenn sie gutes zitat finden was sie
prägnant halten könnte das auch als
titel nehmen als obertitel obertitel
opa titel
ok haben sie dazu fragen mir das ist
also jetzt einfach mal die eröffnung sag
jetzt mal dieser arbeit und unterschätzt
sie den titel nicht
der titel ist dasjenige was man als
erstes liest man liest nicht erst die
einleitung sondern man liest erst den
titel also mit dem titel können sie viel
gutmachen ich sage jetzt nicht falsch
aber gut machen kann man mit dem titel
durchaus einiges dann beginnen sie das
ist ja auch noch ein punkt das kommt ja
auch noch vor der einleitung nach dem
titel kommt dann erst mal das
inhaltsverzeichnis und das verweist dann
eigentlich schon auf die gliederung weil
sich das internetverzeichnis natürlich
nur erst dann erstellen lassen können
ich sage jetzt bewusst nicht schreiben
weil sie das ja nicht eintippen sind das
inhaltsverzeichnis erstellt ihnen der
computer automatisch über die option
formatvorlage wenn sie nicht wissen wie
das geht wenn man sich so ein
inhaltsverzeichnis automatisch erstellen
das dann googeln sie einfach mal alles
sieht so aus dass ich dann eben im text
wenn sie jetzt einmal das erste kapitel
sie haben schreiben das zweite kapitel
das verträgt dezenten zweites kapitel
und dann kommt hier unter der text
sollte text hier dann markieren sie
dieses zweite kapitel mit der maus also
diesen text des zweiten kapitels und
gehen dann obenauf die menüleiste bei
ihrem schreibprogramm und dann müssten
sie unter die option formatvorlage
unter dieser option müssten sie ja den
markierten titel einige ordnung zu
weisen und wenn jetzt eben dass der
erste punkt ist es gebe ja auch noch die
möglichkeit dass die gliederung 2.2 ist
dann ist es die zweite ordnung wenn sie
aber erstens zweitens drittens oder so
weiter haben sind sie auf den ersten
liedes ebene dann markieren sie das
leben auf der ersten führungsebene und
punkte wie 2.2 2.3 auf als zweite
gliederung es eben und punkte wie 1.1.1
der dritten gesehen also einfach wie
viele punkte sie danach haben so viel so
die soundsovielte gliederung ebene ist
es wenn sie das nicht schon wissen dann
googeln sie einfach mal das finden sich
sehr leicht gibt es auch auf youtube
gute einführung vielleicht das kommt mir
jetzt bei dieser gelegenheit vielleicht
erstelle ich selbst ein youtube-video
als ein screencast wo ich das mit der
mit meinem desktop zeige ich habe
nämlich ein programm mit dem man solche
screencast aufnehmen kann aber zeige ich
ihnen das als in meine welt programm
nicht an den mauszeiger eben dann
dorthin navigieren
hier oben hin und erst dann mache das
kommt mir jetzt erst gerade weil das
machen sehr viele youtube und die
kriegen sehr viele klicks dadurch ist
also eine glaube ich eine ganz gute
sache also gliedern sie eben die arbeit
grundsätzlichen einleitung hauptteil
schluss und der hauptteil kann daneben
das sagen aber gleich noch weiter
untergliedert werden sie müssen auch
nicht ein leid die einleitung einleitung
nennen sie können auch die einleitung
überschreiben mit einer frage sollte nur
daraus hervorgehen dass es dabei um die
einleitung geht können auch eine frage
an stelle von erstens einleitung wählen
auch anstelle von zwei hauptteile können
sie auch irgendwo etwas anderes werden
sollte einfach draußen klar hervorgehen
das ist jetzt nicht hier um den
haupthahn oder gegebenenfalls liebe um
den schluss
dann weisen sie eben die verwendete
literatur das kann einmal die haupt
literatur sein also der primär tags die
primär literatur das sind dann die werke
um die es ihnen geht also zum beispiel
berg song oder schelling oder kant oder
augustinus und gegebenenfalls noch
sekundärliteratur also werke die über
diese werke geschrieben wurden
das ist ganz spannend auch wenn
schelling über kant schreibt in seiner
zeit theorie ist schellings werk für uns
kein sekundär werk ist ein primär werk
obwohl es eigentlich dieser logik nach
eigentlich sich auf etwas bezieht aber
schellings theorie bezieht sich ebenso
auf ganz theorie dass es nicht nur ein
kommentar ist sind dass er das
weiterdenkt und ist also ein bisschen
eine graduelle geschichte oder eine eine
sache die nicht so klare grenzen hat ab
wann jetzt eine sekundärliteratur
insofern sie sich auf eine andere
literatur bezieht sekundärliteratur ist
oder vielleicht nicht aufgrund dieses
eigenständigen bezugs doch wiederum eine
primär literatur lässt also ganz
spannend ich denke mal als schelling
angefangen hatte sich mit kahn zu
verpassen waren seine schriften er
sekundärliteratur also kommentare zu
kants schriften ja zb seine magister
dissertation da zitierte noch sehr viel
auskannte hatten das gefühl da ist er
noch sehr abhängig von cannes aus der
heutigen zeit wird immer schellings
magister die situation wohl als einen
primär text ansehen also als ein
eigenständiges werk weil darin dann
irgendwie schon weitere gedanken
angelegt sind die schelling später
entwickelt hatte
es ist immer so ein bisschen eine
graduelle sache aber alle werke die wir
hier lesen als alle werke denen wir eine
sitzung hier widmen gilt bei uns als
primäre texte und sekundär texte da habe
ich ihn ja auch noch eine e mail
geschickt zu einem dropbox link haben
sie denn alle gekommen den dropbox link
da habe ich einen eigenen ordner
sekundärliteratur also zb eine literatur
von
rüdiger safranski ob man die jetzt
zitieren muss ist die frage das könnte
man jetzt als sekundärliteratur werden
oder eben von cord friebe dieses werk
über raumzeit ich habe da einige sachen
rein ich werde auch noch weitere stellen
das sind dann ganz klar sekundär text
und in dem ordner primär literatur das
sind eben alle texte drin die wir hier
hauptsächlich behandelt haben
gute frage als sie können entweder so
zitieren das eben nach dem satz ist der
satz aber sieht eine fußnote setzen und
dann hier in dem anmerkung style die
anmerkung reinschreiben oder den
nachweis was auch immer oder dass sie
eben den satz haben oder auch nur ein
begriff
zitat und dann danach die nachweis
bringen
in klammer das können sie auch machen
sie müssen es eben einheitlich machen
also das wie gesagt ihr seid die
angelsächsische weise dass man nach dem
satz den nachweis tritt in klammern
bringt da empfiehlt sich natürlich dann
kurz titel zu verwenden wenn sie jetzt
nach diesem satz hier die ganze
literatur angabe ausführlich bringen
also vorname nachname titel ja der
erscheinung und verlags ort und
seitenzahlen dann wird ja der nachweis
länger als der satz das ist natürlich
dann nicht sinnvoll das heißt wenn sie
direkt nach dem satz den klammern
nachweisen müssen sie siegern oder
kurztitel verwenden also zb bei der
sekundärliteratur wäre das zum beispiel
dann müller 2009 10,2 180
das ist jetzt nicht so lang und im
literaturverzeichnis macht schreiben sie
dann das ganze eben aus am ende dann ist
klar dass müller 2009/10 eben diesen
titel hat und in diesem werk erschienen
ist wenn sie also diese sache machen
dann machen wenn sie jetzt hier mit
fußnote zitieren können sie das genauso
machen
sie können aber auch dann das ganze
länge ausschreiben wie sie wollen und
bei der situation von primär texten
da können sie eben auch kürzel verwenden
also zb kpv für kants kritik der
praktischen vernunft oder zb bild alte
wie kürzlich das am besten ab
das eigentlich schon sehr kurz aber ich
könnte auch noch weiter abkürzen
wa das machen die meisten weh aber wir
machen sie einfach noch hier das mit die
band zahl ich weiß nicht in welche band
römisch und dann hier 83 so und dann
machen sie eben im literaturverzeichnis
am ende lösen sie das auf also diese
kurzzeitige und auch die zyklen dann
machen sie in zeeland verzeichnis
anschreiben sind wa gleich weltalter
können sie aber auch in einer der ersten
fußnoten machen und schreibe den
folgenden kürzlich weltalter mit wa
das ist ganz ihnen überlassen es muss
einfach nur für den leser klar daraus
hervorgehen was sie jetzt damit meinen
dann bis jetzt das wichtigste in der
einleitung sollten sie eine
fragestellung aufwerfen die für die
arbeit zentral ist und dabei geht es mir
nicht um irgendeine frage sein um ein
problem und zwar nicht um ein zweites
problem also was ist zeit das ist zum
beispiel eine zweite frage die frage die
haben wir uns für dieses ganze semester
vorgenommen aber nicht für eine
hausarbeit ist diese frage vielleicht
ein bisschen zu weit
also dann immer konkretisieren also zb
kann man sehr schön immer diese a3 mit
der baureihe konfrontieren also
subjektive versus objektive zeit
schreiben sie nicht über zeit allgemein
dann schreiben sie über einen bestimmten
aspekt hat eine bestimmte theorie
derzeit wie stehling diana derzeit
interpretieren das ist total spannend
also suchen sie immer noch so ein
problem nach was wirklich interessant
ist wenn sie das nicht interessant
finden dann schreiben sie da am besten
gar nicht drüber jeder findet ja auch
andere dinge interessant und also
probleme dieses problems sollten sie in
der einleitung angeben also sie
schreiben ihm folgen denn diese arbeit
behandelt sich mit folgendem problem zum
beispiel und das problem ist folgendes
also wie können wir die subjektive zeit
erfahrung bei schelling zum beispiel wer
jetzt eine möglichkeit die die sahara
entspricht dann müssen sie kurz erklären
was im jahr auf sich hat wie können wir
die so denken dass sie dennoch objektiv
ist wenn wir zum beispiel über
geschichte spricht geschichte ist sie
eine rede über die vergangenheit die
jetzt nicht nur so subjektiv ist
geschichte ist so eine art fundament auf
dem wir alle stehen und wie können wir
das verstehen die geschichte also
erklären sie dem leser kurz worum es
geht
machen sie das durchaus explizit sehr
nachvollziehbar
und dann schreiben sie in der einleitung
wie sie im folgenden im hauptteil diese
frage dann behandeln wollen
sie schreiben dann um diese fragen zu
klären die ich jetzt gerade aufgeworfen
habe werde ich im hauptteil
folgendermaßen vorgehen erst wird das
tun dann würde ich das tun
und dann würde ich das tun also im
idealfall haben sie es dann auch mit
einem gedankengang zu tun dass also
jeder schritt im hauptteil auf den
vorher gingen irgendwie logisch
aufgebaut also notwendig auseinander
erfolg natürlich ist nicht ganz so
notwendig wie man ein bisschen
willkürlich aber dass sie eben zeigen
dass das ganze durch komponiert ist das
wäre schon das ist ganz irgendwie so ein
begründetes und begründung zusammenhang
wichtig ist mir auch dass sie versuchen
zu argumentieren was sind die gründe
dafür was sind die gedanken die dagegen
sprechen und wie entscheide ich mich
dass das wäre mir auch ganz wichtig
genau und dann auch noch wichtig zitate
sprechen für sich
also sie können natürlich auch gerne
soll sogar zentrale zitate verwenden
ich habe durch die folien die ich ihnen
immer aus teile schon so eine
vorselektion vorgenommen das heißt dass
es in meinen augen die zentralen zitat
aber wenn sie noch andere zentrale
zitate finden die für ihre leitfrage
zentral sind können sie natürlich gerne
nehmen aber zitieren sie nicht einfach
so also das jetzt hier das zitat bringen
sondern erläutern sie das immer auch
also sagen sie diese these meine
interpretations these wird durch dieses
zitat belegt dann bringen sie das zitat
und dann können sie den nachweis haben
hier sieht man ganz genau dass shell
jetzt davon spricht denn davon und dann
davon als und sie tat spricht für sich
das ist einfach das wichtigste thema
einleiten und auch immer kommentieren
genau da hatte ich schon gesagt im
hauptteil sollten sie dieses thema die
leitfrage zu differenziert behandeln und
in verschiedene gedanken schritte
zerlegen das ist dann die gliederung es
ebene 2 also 2.1 zb 2.2 2.3
vielleicht haben sie auch noch einen
vierten punkt aber in der regel reichen
sofia gliederung punkte auf der zweiten
ebene des haupt teils nennt die können
sie auch jeder jeweils dann wieder mit
dem obertitel bezeichnet also zb jetzt
2.1 ist schellings tiergeschichte 2.2
ist schellings verständnis des
organismus 2.3 ist schillings
verständnis der theologie und 2.4 ist
dann wie schellings theorie der zukunft
so hat zum beispiel das sollte natürlich
miteinander zusammenhängen und am ende
geben sie eine zusammenfassung also was
ist jetzt ihr ergebnis bezogen auf den
der einleitung auf gefragt worauf eine
leitfrage und sie können auch noch wenn
sie wollen punkte markieren die sie
einfach nicht mehr behandeln konnten
oder offene fragen was sie gerne eben
noch getan hätten was aber eben die zeit
nicht mehr hergegeben hat oder der
verfügbare raum
dann machen sie eine
literaturverzeichnis haben alle schon
kurz angesprochen und das unterteilen
sie in primär literatur als alle texte
die in einen ordner primär literatur
drin sind die können sie dann daran
ordnen und alle texte oder auch noch
andere die sie finden die ihn sekundär
texte sind unter dem titel
sekundärliteratur auflisten und
alphabetisch zb nachname vorname also
nachnamen müller vorname anneliese titel
schillings sowie der geschichte ort
münchen jahr 2019 vielleicht zitieren
sie auch noch einen zeitschriften
aufsatz können sie dann noch zusätzlich
machen wo ist das erschienen das machen
sie dann ohne ort und jahr bei
zeitschriften gibt man das jahr schon
einmal nicht den ort das auto gibt wird
nicht an
und das jahr aber schon aber ist ganz
und jetzt kommt noch was wichtiges
bietet zitieren sie nie aus
internetquellen wie wikipedia
obwohl ich das auch gerne mir anschaue
aber nie um daraus zu zitieren sondern
um dort hinweise auf gutes auf gute
sekundärliteratur zu bekommen sie ziehen
sie bitte nicht nach wikipedia und
zitieren sie auch nicht durch auch nicht
andere texte die sie einfach so im
internet finden es sei denn es handelt
sich dabei um wissenschaftliche aufsätze
jetzt frage ich an sie zurück warum
sollte man nicht aus wikipedia zitieren
ist doch eigentlich ganz praktisch das
könnte jetzt dagegen sprechen überlegen
sie mal
ja das ist eine möglichkeit genau ja
auch punkt alles irgendwie sind die
nicht so streng wissenschaftlicher die
hand also ist auch tennis sehr richtig
also im zimmer die die
qualitätsstandards sind nicht so hoch
bei wikipedia wobei ich unter uns jetzt
sage wie gibt einige wikipedia artikels
sind von ihrer qualität höher als manche
im wissenschaftlichen publikation
veröffentlichte texte also was man
teilweise da liest ist schlechter als
auf wikipedia
aber ich glaube der entscheidende grund
ist der dass die keinen autor und keine
autorin haben die diesen artikel zu
verantworten sie sehen dann immer wenn
sie mal einen verlauf gehen ist unter
jedem jemand der autorin oder autor von
wikipedia ist hat die von ihnen schon
mal jemand was geschrieben oder was
korrigiert also ich habe das schon ein
paar mal gemacht ich bin da auch so
koautor aber ich schreibe dann ließ und
ganz neuen aufsatz artikel sondern ich
korrigiere eben dinge ja als jetzt da
ist der falsche geputzt das falsche
geburtsdatum eingeschrieben da ist ein
wort falsch da fehlt was da könnte man
noch etwas ergänzen und dann mache ich
das natürlich nicht unter seinem
richtigen namen ein pseudonym
ja und wenn sie dann den verlauf sich
anschauen diese wikipedia dass wir die
pga artikels also wer da alles
mitgearbeitet hat ne ist ja so eine
kooperation sonderartikel das schreibt
die noch mit der noch mit der findet was
dann wird es in frage gestellt dann wird
das ganze den haufen geworfen dann sehen
sie da ungefähr 20 bis 30 autoren die
daran beteiligt sind aber alle eben
nicht mit ihrem eigentlichen namen sense
mit mit mit pseudonymen und das bringt
ihn nichts können sie nicht zitieren
also dass sie brauchen eigentlich immer
ein oder zwei oder drei wie auch immer
wir viele auch immer autorinnen autoren
die dafür geradestehen mit ihrem
wirklichen namen und das haben sie
einfach mal wichtig peter nicht sie
haben schon eine gewisse
qualitätskontrolle
aber die ist wie sie glaube richtig
sagen nichts dass er wissenschaftlich
nicht glaubt die ist er
so ein bisschen was die fairness
anbelangt also wird da jetzt jemand
verleumdet wird darüber jetzt jemand
politisch unliebsame ist unfair
geschrieben wird da jetzt diese frau
diesem mann etwas unterstellt was
vielleicht tendenziös ist und dann
greift die community ein
aber das geht hier er so um politische
gepflogenheiten halten oder den
richtigen umgang miteinander als um das
korrekte wissenschaftliche arbeiten also
bitte nie zitieren und dann gibt es auch
noch dieses peter müller philosophie
lexikon wer von ihnen kennt das peter
müller felix kennen sie nicht doch das
ist ganz interessant können sie mal
drauf schauen ich finde es gar nicht
schlecht aber sie sollten danach auch
nicht zitieren weil das ihr also ich
schätze das möglich sehr aber es ist
eher so was was ein verfasser
geschrieben hat dieser peter müller hoch
interessante persönlichkeit der auch
einiges über sich selbst dort
geschrieben hat was eben ein mann beim
mensch im laufe seines lebens sicher
arbeitet hat aus eigener lektüre aus
einer eigenen art von welt anschauen
das sagt peter müller auch ganz
ausdrücklich und deswegen haben diese
text auch nicht den anspruch auf
wissenschaftliche objektivität seien
eben die gewisse färbung und darf das
würde ich deswegen auch nicht empfehlen
aber sie könnte es als eine anregung
können sie das mal nehmen diese diese
texte peter müllers philosophie lexikon
was sie online finden es sehr
verdienstvolle sache aber eben in meinen
augen nicht geeignet um sie wissen schon
wissenschaftlichen kontext zu zitieren
und achten sie darauf dass sie nicht
plagiieren ich will damit folgendes
sagen wir plagiieren meistens nie
bewusst dass eine spannende sache wie
ein klavier hat zustande kommt sondern
wir
wir tauschen uns selbst in plagiat also
wie täuschen im plagiat nicht andere
sowie täuschen erstmal uns selbst ja
indem wir zum beispiel dann glauben
ach das habe ich doch eigentlich schon
gewusst was da steht
und jetzt brauche ich nicht zitieren das
kennen sie vielleicht von sich ich kenne
das von mir dass ich auf den gedanken
war ich ja eigentlich schon jetzt
schreibe ich es halt so aber ich habe
sie schon gehabt eigentlich so viel
besser als steht und deswegen versuchen
sich da so ein bisschen das sich selbst
zu kontrollieren dem sie eben ganz klar
trennen was ist von ihnen und was es von
jemand anderem
und dazu wäre es wichtig wenn sie nicht
von vornherein schon mit der
sekundärliteratur sich befassen sondern
erstmal sich eigene gedanken machen
immer auf basis des primär textes also
so wie wir sie im seminar machen
wir lesen nur den primär text gelesen
zentrale auszüge davon und machen uns
unsere eigene gedanken dazu die gedanken
die wir hier machen die sind nicht
geklaut die sind von uns wir haben dann
nichts anderes gelesen haben vielleicht
ein bisschen vorwissen aber das können
wir nicht mehr direkt zuordnen
das ist allgemeinwissen und wenn wir
unseren eigenen zugang erarbeitet haben
dann könnten wir mal schauen was in der
sekundärliteratur steht habe jetzt nicht
um das zu ergänzen was wir da haben
sondern wir sollten erst dann die
sekundärliteratur schauen wenn wir einen
punkt sind wo wir sagen können mit
dieser interpretations these kann ich in
eine diskussion eintreten
ich habe jetzt eine hypothese
interpretations these zu meinetwegen
schellings zeitverständnis und es
scheint mir mal hoch interessant zu sein
jetzt schaue ich mal wieder dass die
sekundärliteratur sieht also was andere
dazu sagen und dann kann ich von meiner
position aus und diese kontrolle darüber
geben
das ist der idealfall dass sie nur dann
in die sehqualität seecontainer
übergehen wenn sie ihre eigene these wie
sie eigenständig gewonnen haben
verteidigen wollen oder vielleicht auch
korrigieren lassen wollen dann sagen
hier hier hier muss sich dieser person
recht geben
hier kann man das so nicht sehen da
müssen sie das natürlich nachweisen wenn
sich korrigieren lassen wollen oder eben
noch besseren fall werden sie schreiben
hier person xy wenn sie meint dass
schillings 2
verständnis so zu verstehen ist weil ich
verstehe das ja viel besser dann können
sie natürlich auch der sehr kompakten
aber ansonsten wird ich das jetzt mit
gesagt meine meinung es gibt andere
dozierende hier an der lmu dies sind das
ganz anders als ich also ich bin eher
der meinung man sollte möglichst sparsam
mit sekundärliteratur umgehen zumindest
in wissenschaftlichen hausarbeiten die
jetzt noch keine abschlussarbeiten sind
weil man so viel mehr darauf abgerichtet
wird sei hier schon fast im eigenständig
zu denken dass sie können sich dadurch
wirklich einen raum schaffen in dem erst
mal nur ihre eigenen gedanken zählen und
sich mal erstmal auch fernhalten von
anderen meinungen und erst dann auf
diese andere meinung soll kommen wenn
sie schon eigene these entwickelt hat
also thesen sind das entscheidende nicht
meine thesen muss eine pointe haben eine
these muss ein aha effekt haben these
muss neues licht auf eine sache werden
dann haben sie die these und diese these
können sie verteidigen also thesen sind
ganz wichtig sie müssen zu thesen kommen
lesen sind häufig auch argumente die
irgendwas was neues jetzt nicht kann
revolution abermals ohne neuzugang
tendenziell so interessanten zugang
jedenfalls herstellen und so einen
anderen zugang kann eben so erfolgen
dass sie ein text aus einer ganz
bestimmten perspektive befragen
das ist sein bisher hat man das so
gelesen diesen text jetzt lese ich
einmal andersrum albert einstein hat
auch nichts anderes gemacht der hat eben
auch die welt mal von der anderen
perspektive gelöst wie wäre es denn wenn
das licht geben wenn es eine absolute
geschwindigkeit geben oder wenn sich
nicht geschwindigkeit nicht addieren auf
bewegung wie wäre es denn dann denkt man
das mal weiter sie müssen jetzt hier
keine genialen werke schaffen aber ich
denke im prinzip ist es doch ganz
ähnlich
ja und damit haben wir eigentlich schon
sage ich jetzt haben wir eine
dreiviertelstunde hier darüber geredet
die erste hälfte dieser heutigen sitzung
exakt genutzt haben wir uns jetzt damit
fast haben sie eine rückfragen zur
erstellung von hausarbeiten ich mache
noch ein screencast das ist für mich
auch mal was neu ist wie man sowas
formatiert ok dann gehen wir noch mal
kurz zurück jetzt war ja eine lange
winter- weihnachtspause zur letzten
sitzung wie heißt dieser nette herr hier
von dem sie eine bürotür pi hier sehen
wissen sie das noch ja das ist der
friedrich wilhelm joseph schelling
nachdem die straße benannt ist die sich
hinter ihm befindet die sich zirka 20
meter hinter ihnen befinden und das ist
also eine vorform der fotografie und sie
sehen aber wirklich wieder im alter
ausgesehen hat und er hat eine schrift
verfasst die heißt die bild alter und da
hat er verschiedene entwürfe verfasst
und diese welt all das sind auch
fragment geblieben die hat er nicht
fertiggeschrieben die welt alter werden
schon fast sein spät schrift gezählt
seiner spät philosophie obwohl der gute
herr der erst 36 jahre alt war
da hat bei ganz schön seine spät
philosophie das heißt der hat schon sehr
früh angefangen was zu schreiben als
seine philosophie hat er mit 20
geschrieben und seine mittlere
philosophie hat er mit anfang dreißig
geschrieben kann aber auch so gelesen
werden wenn seine spielphilosophie schon
in recht jungen jahren anfingen dass er
einfach im hohen alter nichts mehr
rechts geschrieben hat nichts mehr neues
wenn man es ist könnte man das so sagen
bei georg wilhelm friedrich hegel ist es
nämlich gerade andersherum
er hat ein bisschen mehr zeit gebraucht
bis dir mal in die gänge kam der hatten
mit 20 noch nichts bedeuten dass
geschrieben wo schelling schon viel
weiter waren hegel hat dafür mit 40 50
losgelegt und bei immanuel kant ist es
noch viel extremer immanuel kant hat
erst mit ende 50 anfang 60 seine großen
regel geschrieben
zu alt wurden dort manche menschen gar
nicht mehr also der hat da begonnen wo
die anderen schon längst fertig waren
und er ist von allen dreien nach der
meinung vieler der bedeutendsten
philosophen also man muss da nicht zu
früh schon loslegen ist jetzt aber
natürlich ein anderes thema die zeit
muss irgendwann eben reif sein und jetzt
fassen wir hier mal kurz zusammen was
schelling hier gesagt hat er kann darauf
auch schon kurz zu sprechen
in dem quiz was wir zu beginn der
heutigen sitzung gemacht hatten und ich
möchte jetzt hier die wichtigsten punkte
noch einmal ganz kurz hier in
vergegenwärtigen also einmal denkt
schelling diarra derzeit nicht subjektiv
sondern objekt das ist jetzt meine
thesen
darüber können wir können wir durchaus
diskutieren könnte auch für sich mal
überlegen das will ich jetzt einfach mal
so dahingestellt lassen
sarah die ja eigentlich subjektiv ist
das wird natürlich ständig bestreiten
dass zeit erfahrung was subjektive ist
aber möchte dass gerade objektiv denken
möchte eben von geschichte von der
vergangenheit als etwas sprechen was
nicht nur so irgendwie verflogen ist
sondern was präsent ist und was auch für
unsere gegenwart und für unsere zukunft
von großer bedeutung ist als er denkt
das vergangene viel objektiver also
nicht wie augustinus das vergangene ist
nichts das vergangen ist verflogen das
ist vorbei sondern das vergangene ist
sagt die basis auf der alles andere
auftritt und wir hatten dann gesagt
schelling hat also eine sanduhr modell
der zeit
ich finde es jetzt eigentlich gar nicht
so schlecht weil sie grenzt sich
eigentlich davon ab ein bisschen aber
irgendwie finde ich es dann doch
zutreffend wenn es diesmal so vorstellen
sie haben hier oben so ein glas sie
haben sie den durchgang haben sie hier
das unter glas
jetzt haben sie hier sand drin
dann tritt
hier und der sand rieselt hier so runter
und haben sie hier
neben die diese zeit eigentlich muss man
zu machen musste hier so ein bisschen
angehäuft so tröpfelt dann die zeit aus
der zukunft durch unser jetzt hinab
gegenwart zukunft vergangenheit
ich hatte das erst mal so angeführt als
ein als ein modell was schelling nicht
entspricht aber es entspricht ihm schon
ein bisschen weil eben die vergangenheit
sich auftürmt und wir treten hier als
ist nicht einfach weg und das sammelt
sich etwas an und könnte das jetzt auch
so denken hier gibt es verschiedene
schichten
wenn wir hier oben jetzt verschiedenes
rein fühlen was da auf uns zukommt dann
sind gibt es jetzt demente ablagerungen
in verschiedenen schichten gibt es hier
eine schicht geschichte könnte es
natürlich noch weiter denke hier
riesengroß und hier gibt es eine schicht
hier eine und hier und können wir hier
in die vergangenheit runtergehen graben
eine archäologie betreiben und so stellt
sich eben schelling die zeit vor
also wir haben ja gesagt ist ein
vertikales modell weil eben nicht mehr
so ein horizontales modell wo die
zukunft hier auf uns zukommt hier
durchläuft und hier in der vergangenheit
erm ii verpflichtet
deswegen will ich dieses zentrum oder
gar nicht so schlecht aber er denkt sich
das natürlich nicht genauso aber
irgendwie hat es was die die
vergangenheit ist präsent und sie türmt
sich so auf ich habe wirklich noch was
anderes hier kurz anmerken das ist auch
noch wichtig das ist in der modernen
debatte häufig zentrales problem wenn
wir jetzt überlegen sie mal was
existiert eigentlich von uns oder von
den dingen jetzt in der zeit eigentlich
existiert ja von uns nur das
gegenwärtige das jeweils gegenwärtige
und unsere zeit teile der vergangenheit
irgendwie nicht und deswegen gibt es
diesen versuch raum und zeit auch
ähnlich wie beim in kowski das samt zu
nehmen ich habe es schon mal ihnen
gezeigt für einige das heißt dass wir
hier die zeit haben und hier haben den
raum dann haben wir hier so eine art
zeit wo mit zeit teil als wir sind dann
praktisch nicht etwas was nur zu einem
bestimmten zeitpunkt existiert sondern
wir sind letztendlich alles seit unserer
geburt in dem raum in dem der raumzeit
fortgeführt wir haben zeit zu sagen uns
zeit scheiben oder zeit teil
das war eben zum zeitpunkt t1 oder tx
wäre auch über wir sind zu sein so ein
schlauch der sich durch die raumzeit
zieht so kann man natürlich auch
verstehen es machen sehr wenige aber das
wäre eine möglichkeit das auch noch und
denken wir sind zu sagen wir haben
zeitliche teile haupt zeitliche teile
und existieren nicht nur seine
bestimmten zeitpunkt weil wir ja dann
aufhören zu existieren in der verstand
das ist auch noch möglichkeit okay das
jetzt so ein kleiner exkurs also das ist
mal eine möglichkeit hier das bei stelle
zu interpretieren dann ist das ist
ähnlich wie hier zeit ist bei stelle
mich horizontal hierzu ist vertikal
geschichtet schilling spielt das heißt
von schichten schelling die zeit als
subjekt selbst etwas organisches und
ganz die von einem mechanistischen
zeitverständnis ab das war so ein
bisschen das problem bei uns wie man die
zeit jetzt als ein subjekt denken kann
ganz schwierig aber sie erinnern sich es
gibt bei schelling zwei prinzipien die
überhaupt geschichte oder zeitlichen
verlauf erst ermöglichen es gibt einen
vor drängendes prinzip
und wenn das alleine wirken würde dann
wäre gar keine zeit weil dann wäre auf
einen schlag alles geschehen
das ist diese technologie da strebt
etwas zu etwas hin so denken die
weltgeschichte auf einen bestimmten
punkt punkt hin wenn nur dieses treiben
dem moment am werk wäre dann wäre ich da
keine zeit gar keine geschichte weil
dann wären wir gleich da wenn wir diesem
ziel gleich folgen könnten hätten wir
das gleich erreicht und deswegen zeigt
schöne es gibt noch etwas hemmendes
etwas was eigentlich sich widersetzt
seine art trägheit diesem drängenden und
im zusammenspiel von dringendem und
hemmenden ergibt sich erst diese
sukzessive zeit entwicklung finde ich
ganz interessant aber das ist natürlich
dann schon so wo man sich dass man sich
fragen muss ja wohl kommt denn jetzt
dieses prinzip und wie kann das genauer
erklären aber so als eine grund
erklärung dafür dass eben zeit sich
vollzieht vielleicht auch ein ziel hat
aber eben nicht sofort dieses ziel
erreicht ist es ganz ganz interessant
sage ich
das in aller kürze zu schilling und
jetzt kommen wir zu diesen netten herren
hier weiß man wie dieser herr heißt das
ist der herr der heutigen sitzung genau
und hat ein buch geschrieben zeit und
freiheit ist glaube ich erst 1910
überhaupt ins deutsche übersetzt worden
und wir das ist jetzt ein schwieriger
text und der text gehört der so
genannten strömung der phänomenologie an
ich schreib das auch mal hin
das ist immer so eine schwierigkeit ich
sagen zu klassifizieren hab ich mir
phänomenologie er steht drin das
phänomen das ist dass die erscheinung
und das ist eben die logik könnte man
sagen oder gibt die die lehre die lehre
von der erscheinung also die logik der
erscheinung wie die erscheinung das was
uns erscheint zu interpretieren ist
und zwar spielt ihren ganz wichtige
rolle die reflexion eben auf die zeit
erfahrung also wirklich zeit erfahrung
erfahre ich zeit also wenn ich mich
jetzt auf mich selbst mal konzentrieren
sie kennen alle dieses buch auf der
suche nach der verlorenen zeit dass
kamen sie bestimmt alle lesen oder mal
gehört ist ja sehr umfangreich und da
gibt es ja diese szene wo eben der
protagonist ein gebäck in einem t punkte
und daneben viele synästhetische
assoziationen hat und das ist auch seine
phänomenologische beschreibung und die
phänomenologie versucht neben sich sehr
zu konzentrieren auf ganz ganz
vermeintlich unscheinbare akte und die
dann aber wirklich ihn bis ins letzte
detail zu an sind zu entfalten
in ihrer logik der erscheinung das macht
jetzt hier diese herberg song genau so
und wir haben jetzt ein paar leitfragen
die bestimmt werks um das phänomen der
zeitdauer also du ri die dauer ist das
ganz entscheidende für ihn der begriff
der dauer des andauernden die verhält
sich berg songs theorie zur a und b
derzeit erhalten sie nach bergs raum und
zeit zueinander und in welcher hinsicht
kritisiert berg song kann es
zeitverständnis es wird wieder ein
bisschen darauf hinauslaufen das kann
zum mechanistischen modell anhaftet das
hatte auch schon schelling an kant
kritisiert
weil kann irgendwie wie mir scheint es
ein bisschen nur die also vor allem die
b3 ganz starken macht nadia rey ist bei
ihm nicht so
er redet und redet nicht viel über die
gegenwart nicht viel über die
vergangenheit über geschichte ein
bisschen aber nicht im rahmen dieser
zeit leer im engeren sinne und über die
zukunft sagt eigentlich auch nicht so
viel
ok dann kann man mal hier einfach mal
anfangen mit einem text schließt bevor
wir drücken uns notwendig durch das ist
aus der einleitung jetzt was ich jetzt
voll ist drücken uns nur wenn ich durch
worte aus und denken und wir denken fast
immer räumlich und anderen worten die
sprache zwingt uns und unter unseren
vorstellungen dieselben schafen und
genaue unterscheidung dieselbe
diskontinuität herzustellen wie zwischen
den materiellen gegenständen diese
assimilation ist im praktischen leben
von nutzen und der mehrzahl der
wissenschaften notwendig es ließe sich
jedoch die frage aufwerfen ob nicht
übersteigen überstaatlichen
schwierigkeiten die gewisse
philosophische problem bieten daher
kommen dass man dabei behält die
erscheinungen die kahlen raum einnehmen
im rahmen neben einander zuordnen und ob
sich der streit nicht oft dadurch
beenden ließe dass man von den allzu
großen bildern abstrahiert um die er
sich abspielen wenn eine unberechtigte
übersetzung des un- ausgedehnten ein
ausgedehntes der qualität in quantität
ins innere der aufgeworfenen frage
selbst den widerspruch hinein trägt ist
es dann zu verwundern dass sich der
widerspruch in den lösungen die man ihr
gibt wiederfindet was ist jetzt hier das
problem auf das werk songs zu sprechen
kann
wir haben das auch schon mal ganz kurz
angesprochen in einer sitzung am anfang
es geht hier also um methodologische
probleme wie wir überhaupt sinnvoll über
zeitliches sprechen können
was kritisiert er jetzt darüber was es
für ihn jetzt hier problematisch
wer kommt dass man von zeit fast immer
decken entspricht und entsprechend
probleme auf können die man genau mit
diesen aussagen
in zu tun welche eigenschaft zurzeit
genau haben sie denn ein beispiel
überlegen sie mal alle wie wir räumlich
über die zeit im alltag sprechen meine
these ist die wir reden zu
selbstverständlich räumlich über die
zeit dass wir das gar nicht mehr merken
ja genau
genau das merken wir gar nicht mehr aber
länge ist eine räumliche eigenschaft
dinge ist eine größe der physik wir
sagen manchmal zeitdauer
damit versuchen wir dann die länge von
der dauer zu unterscheiden also die die
räumlichkeit von der zeitlichkeit
unterscheidet da war noch eine meldung
ja richtig genau das ist dann ganz klar
eine metapher aber heutzutage merkt man
also man merkt das passt schon ein
bisschen mehr wenn man sagt zeitraum
ich würde mal sagen die rede von dem
zeitraum ist metaphorisch eindeutiger
als die rede von derzeit länge jetzt mal
eine these aber wenn wir von derzeit
lägen gesprächen oder wenn wir vom
zeitraum besprechen
verheimlichen wir die zeit in beiden
fällen bzw
wir verwenden einmal die zweite
dimension an
und einmal die dritte die mütze genau
genommen also die räumliche zweite
dimension zeit länger brauchen wir nur
zwei dimensionen als metaphorisch zu
sprechen und ein mal eben die dritte
dimension noch die metaphorische
hinsicht wären also gesagt das war jetzt
aber eine kurze zeit das ging jetzt aber
schnell
dann würde niemand heutzutage denken das
ist aber eine unangemessene rede von der
zeit
und jetzt sagt er hier also dass man
eben die erscheinungen die keinen raum
einnehmen und besitzt genau das objekt
seiner phänomenologie es geht also um
erscheinungen um phänomene phänomen ist
es die erscheinung um erscheinungen die
keinen raum einnehmen und die wollen wir
dann aber im raum nebeneinander ordnen
also zum beispiel zeit erfahrung sind
erscheinungen die keinen raum einnehmen
also das ist das problem
jetzt haben wir hier schon eine
unberechtigten übersetzung des un-
ausgedehnten als zeitlichen die frage
ist ob das zeitlich nicht doch irgendwie
ausgedehnt ist hinausgeht in der
qualität also vielleicht die zeit die
das qualitative ist etwas bloß
quantitative das ist so die leitfrage
die wir hier haben und wir werden sehen
dass eigentlich schelling ähnliche
gedanken hier schon hatte und dass
martin heidegger auf denen wir in der
nächsten und übernächsten sitzung
ausführlicher zu sprechen kommen werden
hier offensichtlich anknüpft dieses
problem der vereinigung der zeit
es fällt uns aber unglaublich schwer uns
die dauernd ihrer ursprünglichen
reinheit vorzustellen und das kommt
zweifellos daher das nicht allein wir
die äußeren dinge so scheint es dauern
gleich uns und die zeit von diesem
gesichtspunkt ausgesehen gewinnt ganz
das aus zehn eines homogenen mediums
nicht nur erscheint im moment dieser
dauer als einander äußerlich wie körper
im raum sollen die von unseren sinnen
per zitierte bewegung ist gewissermaßen
das greifbare zeichen für eine homogene
und messbare bauer
das ist der punkt bei aristoteles der
sagt dass mir zeit eben immer über diese
bewegung versuche zu messen ja noch mehr
die zeit tritt in die formeln der
mechanik in die berechnung des
astronomen und selbst des physikers in
quantitativer form ein wer möchte eine
qualitative stimmung derzeit haben was
auch immer jetzt qualitativ ein mann
misst die geschwindigkeit einer bewegung
und das schließt ein dass die zeit auch
ihrerseits eine größe ist also keine
qualität sind eine qualität selbst die
analyse die wir vorher versucht haben
verlangt von hier aus noch eine
vervollständigung wenn nämlich die dauer
im eigentlichen sinne nicht angibt nicht
gemessen wird was messen dann die
schwingungen der uhr an wird
äußerstenfalls zu geben dass die vom
bewusstsein per zitierte innere dauer in
der ineinander schachtel ung der
bewusstseins vorgänge in der stufenweise
bereicherung dass ich auf gehe die zeit
aber die der astronomen seine formel 1
für die zeit die unsere uhr in gleiche
parzellen teilt diese zeit wird man
sagen ist etwas anderes
sie ist eine messbare größe und folglich
homogen
was ist jetzt das problem wie möchte er
jetzt zeit hier nicht verstehen oder was
möchte erstmal versuchen das sagte im
ersten satz
es geht also um die dauer ihrer
ursprünglichen reinheit
das ist eine ganz typische
phänomenologische herangehens weil sie
wollen die dinge als solche zurück zu
den dingen sagt ja manchmal auch ein
bedeutender phänologie ein bisschen nach
wirksam
wir wollen die dinge so wie sie wirklich
sind betrachten und wir wollen
letztendlich dinge ein klammern das ist
diese epoche
so nennt man das alter dieses
ausschalten dieses ausblenden von
randbedingungen von faktoren die das
phänomen verstellen das phänomen
verfälschen wir wollen dass die das
phänomen reinsehen also die dauer als
solche sind und jetzt sagte herr unten
also es gibt so eine vorstellung der
zeit die diese in gleiche parzellen
teilt und das will also nicht haben das
wieder nicht und jetzt spricht er aber
davor dann wird äußerstenfalls zu geben
dass die vom bewusstsein per zitiert
innere darum jetzt kommt was
interessantes in der ineinander stellung
der bewusstseins vorgänge in der
stufenweise bereicherung dass ich
aufgeben wie verstehen sie das also die
ineinander schachtel ung der
bewusstseins vorgehen
genau also das ist genau der punkt also
wie mir scheint also diese diese
qualität quantitativ analyse derzeit die
kann die einfach so
portionsweise rausnehmen hier machen uns
mit beliebig wir können beliebig
schneiden die zeit und dem gegenüber
steht ein zeitverständnis wo wir
irgendwo die zeiten vielleicht könnte
man sagen also ihr uns auch in gewissen
episoden vortreten oder jedenfalls nicht
mehr vertikal eigentlich mehr horizontal
verlaufen sondern eher vertikal also
diese schachtel schachteln scheint mir
sowas vertikales zu versinnbildlichen
wir haben hier irgendwas muss man
schauen denn das macht also haben wir
vielleicht sowas
die zeit ist dass wir jetzt eine
schachtel und wir können das abgrenzen
von also eine portionierung
also in der schachtel um da ist da
hängen die ganzen miteinander zusammen
sind auch die zur selben zeit sag ich
jetzt mal also ein bisschen paradox aber
sie ist wie sie glaube richtig sei es
wirkt was nach und wir haben nicht die
zeit als etwas separates getrenntes
sondern wir haben die zeit mehr
verbunden oder zeitliche episoden
einheiten haben wir miteinander
verbunden
das wäre die schachtel und es wäre die
parzellen
wie genau jetzt natürlich diese
schachtel vorstellen ist sagte jetzt
hier nicht aber er hat offensichtlich
auch hier
ich sage jetzt mal eher so ein
vertikales modell als ein horizontales
mittel
grund ein wichtiger weiterer begriff ist
hier auch noch der dass der bewusstseins
vorgänger es geht um rost als vorgänger
das heißt berg so möchte die haare
derzeit besonders stark machen möchte
natürlich nicht die arbeit als solche
nur vertreten weil diarra ja auch wie
mir scheint dadurch dass hier von einer
reihe die rede ist auch schon für
räumlich ist 3 ist etwas wo wir
letztendlich freue mich denkt wo wir
längen haben eine reihe reis aufgereiht
im raum und das heißt die rede von der
a3 derzeit sehr stört eigentlich gerade
die einsicht dass nämlich zeit etwas
subjektives ist was der eigenen qualität
hat eben nicht räumlich zu denken ist
das macht eigentlich die rede von der a3
wieder zunichte diese intuition diese
damit eigentlich erfasst hat befolge ich
auf dem zifferblatt einer uhr mit den
augen die bewegung des zeigers die den
schwingungen des pendels entspricht zur
messe ich keine dauer wie man zu glauben
scheint ich beschränke mich vielmehr
darauf simultan eaton zählen was etwas
ganz anderes ist
aristoteles würde wahrscheinlich sagen
aber das ist geben gerade die zeit nun
also eben nach bestimmten bewegungs
periode neben einzuteilen das ist das
ist die zeit dahin besteht sein
das wäre jetzt also ihr seine bären
auffassung die zeit ich beschränke mich
wie gesagt hier nur auf diesem fall auf
simultan eaton außerhalb meiner im raume
gibt es immer nur eine einzige lage des
tigers und des pendels von den
vergangenen lagen bleibt ja nichts
erhalten
ja und das wäre eben anders bei der
schachtel da wäre eben irgendetwas noch
präsent die vergangenheit wäre wie
präsent gestuft
in meinem innern vollzieht sich dagegen
eine orc ein organisations oder
gegenseitige durchdringung prozess der
bewusstseins vorgänger der die ware
dauer ausmacht da haben wir es jetzt das
letzte entscheidende punkt weil ich auf
diese weise dauere deshalb stelle ich
mir was ich die vergangene einen
schwingungen der un vor während ich
gleichzeitig die aktuelle stimmung zieht
ihre prinzipielle heißt wahrnehmen
schalten wir nun einen augenblick dass
ich aus dass dieses sukzessiv genannten
schwingungen denkt es wird es immer nur
eine einzige pendelt schwingung geben
sogar nur eine einzige stellung des
pendels und folglich keine schalten wie
andererseits das pendel und seine
schwingungen aus so gibt es nichts mehr
als die heterogene dauer dass ich ohne
momente die einander äußerlich werden
ohne beziehung zur zahl h
also es ist offensichtlich so
dass das ich und das äußere die bewegung
dass die sich irgendwie zueinander
komplementär also ergänzend verhalten
also wenn ich das ich nicht habe auch
das bewusstsein nicht habe dann gibt es
eigentlich immer nur position also
punkte des pendels ist ja eigentlich
klar wir müssen überlegen wie wird denn
bewegung wahrgenommen
und wenn ich eben das also sagt er jetzt
natürlich ein bisschen jetzt
idealistisch gedacht so etwas aber wenn
sie jetzt mal ganz musikalisch den
können dann haben wir eben zu jedem
zeitpunkt da ist jetzt da sei es oder
was auch immer
dann habe ich eigentlich wenn ihr jetzt
eine bewegung aufzeichnen die bewegung
von irgendwas dann hab ich genau
genommen eigentlich immer nur punkte
also das kann man bis ins unendliche
teil ist damit die frage ist es sind
sind diese zeitpunkt sind die immer
weiter es ist ein kontinuum oder ist es
das gerät erscheint jetzt hier
nahezulegen dass es diskret ist das also
einzelne punkte gibt vielleicht ist auch
eigentlich unerheblich ist letztendlich
kann man jetzt eben immer teil
wir haben also nach ohne dass ich ohne
dass ich was etwas betrachtet haben wir
eigentlich nur solche zeit punkte und
wir haben nicht diesen bogen dem diese
das ereignis beschreibt also dass ich
wäre das wäre sagen es möglich müsste da
so ganz gestrichen so ist weil ich gut
gibt es von gegenständlich in dem ich
hier so kleine abgrenzung macht zeigt
sich dass sich die eigentliche bewegung
damit nicht vollziehen kann ich kann den
zusammenhang dieser bewegung nicht
vollziehen oder erkennen wenn ich immer
nur den einzelnen
der punkt betrachtet und sobald ich eben
das bewusstsein im spiel habe habe ich
eben diese schön
ja das ist glaube ich der unterschied
hier kann ich darauf beziehen da kann
ich seine linie zieht seine linie durch
die zeit punkte ziehen dieses linien
ziehen das ist gerade das was die dauer
ausmacht das ist die dauer dass die
dauer dieser bogen das verbinden
das heißt immer es ist immer so dem zug
zurück der bezug nach vorne
ich knüpfe immer anderen den
vorhergehenden continu ihre diese diese
einzelpunkte und das sagte jetzt bergson
das kann eben die rein räumliche oder
naturwissenschaftliche betrachtung nicht
ist natürlich die frage ist das will ich
nicht kann aber man könnte schon denken
dass zum nach vollzug einer bewegung
eben das vergegenwärtigen und das
erinnern und zu treten muss um diese
schönen bogen zu erzeugen
so findet als und sukzession ohne
reziproke extremität stadt und ich muss
noch einen punkt besprechen das ist wäre
jetzt also ohne dass ich hätten wir
sowas und zusammen mit dem ich und dem
äußeren haben wir das diesen schönen
bogen wenn jetzt aber eben nur dass ich
da ist und nicht diese das äußere also
die die schwingungen der letzte satz
schalten wird andererseits das pendel
und seine schwingungen aus dann haben
wir nur dass ich so gibt es nichts mehr
als die heterogene dauert es ich ohne
moment die äußerlich werden ohne
beziehung zu zahlen das heißt das wäre
irgendwie auch nicht
wir hätten dadurch auch keine zeit keine
zeit erfahrung wenn nichts äußeres
werden zu lesen ich das jetzt
nichts mehr als die heterogene was ist
denn heterogene dauert es ist rogan also
ja ja ich glaube die schachtel und kommt
nur dadurch zustande dass wir eben
äußere erfahrung haben etwas erfahren
können ein gegenstand der erfahrung
heterogen meinte erstmals
zusammenhängend oder
nicht geordnet da hätten wir nichts
geordnetes diese ordnung muss von außen
irgendwie kommen durch durch eine
gewisse regelmäßigkeit der abfolge aber
dieses verbinden zu einer zeit erfahrung
das macht dann dass ich das ich
verbindet verknüpft die einzelnen punkte
miteinander
also es muss irgendwie beides seien das
was äußerst gegeben sein und es muss
dieses bewusstsein wird derzeit
erfahrung auch geben so findet als in
unserem ich sukzession sukzession ist
die aufeinanderfolge die abfolge ohne
reziproke reziprok heißt wechselseitige
extremität heißt äußerlichkeit stadt und
außerhalb des isch reziproke als
wechselweise äußerlichkeit ohne
sukzession
das leuchtet ein und zwar reziproke
extremität weil die gegenwärtige
schwingung von der nicht mehr
bestehenden vorhergegangenen radikal
unterschieden ist sukzession slow sich
kite aber weil es sukzession nur für
einen bewussten beobachter geben kann
der sich das vergangen erinnert und die
zwei schwingung oder ihre symbole in
einem aushilfs halber vorgestellten raum
nebeneinander auf wright zwischen dieser
sukzession ohne exterieur i tät ist
alles reine ich und diese exterieur i
tät ohne sukzession vollzieht sich nun
eine art austausch der von den physikern
sogenannten dem der dem von den
physikern sogenannten phänomen der
andrews mose ziemlich analog ist haben
wir hier einen physiker der weiß was
eine endlose ist
sie kennen alle osmose die osmose wissen
sie was eine osmose ist
als dann irgendwas mit druck zu pflanzen
druck wurzel beim wurzeln bei pflanzen
osmose als endo ist weg was nach nach
nach innen hinein muss noch mal
nachschauen ich präsentieren das dann
nächste sitzung also entscheidend ist
hier dass hier ein austausch stattfindet
ein austausch zwischen dem reinen ich
und dem äußeren der erscheinung
also man könnte sagen komplementär
ergänzen sich also ein reines ich mir so
ein reines ich habe da haben wir eben
keine aufeinanderfolge weil es muss ja
etwas folgen wir haben da etwas
heterogenes wie er sagt und wenn wir
eben nur was äußeres haben
so haben wir eben eigentlich keinen
wirklichen wechsel kein wandel weil eben
wir nur einzelne punkte haben also wir
müssen das ganze verbinden und das
schafften nur dieses ich im zusammenhang
mit diesen äußeren phänomen
den das zitat vielleicht doch die
sukzessiven phasen unseres bewussten
lebens die sich indessen gegenseitig
durchdringen jede für sich genommen
einen simultanen pendelt schwingung
entsprechen
da andererseits diese schwingungen
deutlich voneinander unterschieden sind
insofern die eine nicht mehr ist wenn
die andere eintritt gewöhnen wir uns
daran zwischen den sukzessiven momenten
unseres bewussten lebens dieselbe
unterscheidung aufzustellen
die pendel schwingungen lösen ist
sozusagen ineinander äußerliche teile
auf das würden sich da so eine uhr
vorstellen die immer schwingt hier raus
springt dann die irrtümliche verteilung
der inneren homogenen dem raum analogen
dauern
deren identische momente
aufeinanderfolgen ohne einander zu
durchdringen
andererseits aber profitieren
gewissermaßen die pendel schwingen die
nur deshalb wurde unterschieden sind
weil die eine verschwunden ist wenn die
andere auftritt durch den einfluss den
sie in der geschilderten weise auf
unsere bewusstes leben ausgeübt haben
als er sagt es ist eine ziemliche
vorstellung dass es eine innere dauer
gebe als die bewusstseins dauer die
homogen wäre ja als auch portioniert
werden
das sagte das ist sie nicht sagt dem
vorvorigen zitat das dass die dauer des
ichs als solche heterogen ist das ist
also nicht in sicht portioniert diese
portionierung bekommen wir immer nur
durch das äußere
als das wäre ein irrtum zu glauben wir
werden in unsere dauer als solche
eingeteilt in phasen
das muss von außen kommen interessant
ist auch noch hier im ersten satz dass
diese aufeinander folgenden phasen und
des bewussten lebens da ist die sich
gegenseitig durchdringen
und das könnte man vielleicht ein
bisschen mit dieser stellung auch noch
in verbindung
dass ich das eben anschließe brauchen
diese kontinuität
wenn sie sich nicht durchdringen würden
zur lese ich jetzt das dann hätten wir
eben nur diese einzelnen klar
voneinander unterschieden zeitpunkt und
es muss eine art übergabe also wie so
ein staffellauf ne wie so ein
staffellauf der staffelstab das ist der
eine zeiten muss zum anderen zeitpunkt
überbracht werden muss übergeben es muss
ich so anknüpfen
ich muss eigentlich muss eigentlich
immer hier so kleine übergänge denken
von jedem einzelnen punkt und dieses
dieses übergang herstellen das wäre dann
letztendlich die die funktion des viehs
die das ganze verknüpft miteinander
chronologisch das andere
mit klasse
ja
ich denke das ist richtig ist und ich
denke das ist mit der schachteln gemeint
ist da ist jetzt noch nicht so explizit
aber darauf zu sprechen gekommen
da müssen wir noch ein bisschen schauen
vielleicht schaffen wir noch eins jetzt
komm zum punkt wo so ein rückbezug ist
dank der erinnerung die unsere wurst
sein von ihnen im ganzen organisiert hat
muss heißen werden sie aufbewahrt
als diese zeit punkte und dann
aneinander gereiht kurz wir erschaffen
für sie eine vierte raum dimension die
wir die homogene zeit nennen und die es
möglich macht das die pendelbewegung
obwohl sie sich eigentlich fortschritts
los vollzieht sich jetzt unbegrenzte an
sich selber wright versuchen wir nun in
diesem sehr komplexen prozess den anteil
des wirklichen und das aus der
einbildung standen genau zu bestimmen so
finden wir folgendes es gibt einen
realen raum ohne dauer
wo aber phänomene simultan mit uns an
bewusstseinszustände auftreten und
verschwinden
es gibt eine wirkliche dauer deren
heterogene momente sich gegenseitig
durchdringen vor der aber jeder moment
einem zustand der äußeren welt der zur
selben zeit mit ihm eintritt angenähert
und von den anderen momenten eben durch
diese annäherung abgetrennt werden kann
aus der vergleichen dieser beiden
realität entsteht eine dem raum
entlehnte symbolische vorstellungen von
der dauer
diese nimmt so die illusorische form
eines homogenen mediums an und das
verbindende zwischen diesen beiden
terminen dem raum und der dauer ist das
simultan i tät die man als den
schnittpunkt derzeit mit dem raume
definieren könnte das jetzt ein sehr
gehaltvolle zitat bei dem wir es hier
auch mal belassen wollen also jetzt
kommt hier ein neuer punkt ins spiel
nämlich die erinnerung und die
erinnerung ist etwas was das ganze
organisiert denken sie zurück an
schelling schelling spricht auch von
einer organischen zeit als hat so eine
fügung dass ganzes aufeinander
abgestimmt und sie werden also geordnet
das ist also die erinnerungen
und eigentlich sagt er im vorgehen denn
zitat das die zeit des rhein
bewusstseins heterogen ist also nicht
gleichartig nicht geordnet aber mit der
erinnerung schaffen wir eine homogene
zeit und diese homogene zeit erlaubt ist
dann eine pendelbewegung die ja
eigentlich auf der stelle steht dass wir
diese bewegung dann zeitlich ausdehnen
können dass wir also sagen können es ist
bekommt eine dauer wenn sie immer
dieselbe pendelbewegung sehen dann
müssten sie eigentlich sagen es ist
immer nur die das eine ereignis das ist
nicht ausgedient
vielleicht ausgedehnt einem bestimmten
rahmen aber eben nur so dass
dieses pendel eben einmal hier einmal
hier ist das ist das ganze dass sie aber
das ganze dann eben auch in der zeit
eben haben diese ganzen
aufeinanderfolgen
was sie also eine dauer haben denen sich
diese bewegung erstreckt das wäre dann
eben darauf zurückzuführen dass wir uns
erinnern an das bereits geschehene
pendel oder
mitunter gebe momente
und ja
an der äußeren welt dazu selbst
nicht noch mal
was wir schon
als ich glaube es richtig erst das
entscheidende ist dass sie also sich
raum und zeit an mehr dass sie eine
annäherung stattfindet dass sie sich
annähern und diese annäherung ist sagt
er ist symbolische kommt das symbolische
noch mit nein und das symbolische der
annäherung ist das symbolische derzeit
erfahrung ist dass das wir eben eine
ordnung in die zeit erfahrung
hineinbekommen eine ordnung die
eigentlich dem raum entlehnt ist also
dass wir eben perioden und vollzüge
voneinander unterscheiden können im zeit
erfahren das ist etwas was wird im raum
verdanken so lese ich das und dass wir
diese räumliche struktur mit aufnehmen
können wir auch nur symbolisch das nennt
er dann den schnittpunkt von zeitraum im
letzten satz
das ist eine spannende frage wie wir das
symbolische hier zu verstehen haben
ich denke die heben uns auf für die
nächste sitzung wir haben also noch ein
paar zitate ich gehe hier ganz zum ende
ein paar auszüge die ich selbst
ausgewählt habe wir sehen wir haben hier
also 35 oder 33 das haben wir noch zehn
folien die wir lesen werden die werde
ich ihnen noch herumschicken bzw die
werden sie ab heute dann auch noch auf
der app finden und dann werden wir aber
in der nächsten sitzung in der zweiten
hälfte auch schon auf martin heidegger
zu sprechen kommen